the French foreign minister says peace
between long-time enemies Azerbaijan and
Armenia is possible
Catherine Colona is in Baku for talks
with the azerbaijani president she'll
also meet with Armenian leaders that as
Armenia files a case with the
international court of justice
challenging azerbaijanic checkpoints in
the corridor from Armenia to the
occupied region of nagorno-karabakh the
last major fighting between the two
countries was in 2020.
altaziras Bernard Smith is in Baku now
joins us live from there so it seems
this round a Bernard has been started
with a dispute over checkpoint is the
back story really to all of this though
the waning Russian influence in the
garden of karabakh who they're supposed
to be playing the role of course of
peacekeepers right
you see yes I mean there are Russian
peacekeepers on the main road the Latin
Corridor that links the ethnic albanians
in karabakh to ethnic Armenians excuse
me in karabakh to Armenia proper they
are as a azeries I put a checkpoint up
on there they say because Armenia is
running weapons to karabakh charges of
course Armenia denies but they've done
this under uh the nose if you like of
Russian peacekeepers have been there
since 2020 while the Russian
peacekeepers are there it's the French
foreign minister with us backing who's
here in Baku leading diplomatic efforts
to try and resolve this latest flare-up
that is irritated the Russians the
foreign Ministry spokeswoman saying
today that the US and France are trying
to undermine uh moscow's role in this
region but the fact is peacekeepers
Russian peacekeepers or any peacekeepers
can't really enforce their role at
gunpoint they rely on the power and the
influence of state in this case Russia
that backs them and Azerbaijan seems to
have the suggestion is that with Russia
so focused on Ukraine then it's taken
its Eye Off the Ball here somewhat and
that is why the French and the US have
stepped in to try and resolve this
latest flare-up all right maybe you can
explain to us the concerns of those
ethnic Armenians but perhaps the the as
areas in putting up that checkpoint what
is all of this about
beautiful
well Armenia really suspects that
Azerbaijan is trying to essentially take
over the rest of karabakh by stealth
Azerbaijan in that last war between the
two sides in 2020 took back control of
huge amounts of territory around the
main urban area of karabakh the main
city can candy is what the azaris call
it for the uh Armenians it's the
panicert ethnic Armenians in there and
they want to remain they sort of
separated from uh Azerbaijan it's
internationally recognized as area
territory but it is essentially disputed
and this is why this conflict's been so
long running because they haven't
resolved the final status of this area
Armenia Azerbaijan says it's offered
Armenia dual control over this road
Armenia as it says Armenia hasn't taken
up that offer and that's why these areas
put in this checkpoint but the French
Have Said Today Catherine Colonna said
she does not believe this checkpoint
should be there it could lead to further
Flair drops of violence and the Russians
also said a couple of days ago they
don't believe either side should be
taking unilateral actions anyway
Catherine Colonna it will head on to
yaravan she'll be speaking with the
Armenians about this later and then
she's off to Tbilisi in Georgia Sammy
all right thanks so much Bernard Smith